advanced of yesterday's fan presale the
band's website provided tips for
obtaining tickets but many tell us they
couldn't get them and instead saw the
pop-up immediately on sites like StubHub
at a huge inflation tickets for the
Vancouver show were initially between
116 and 166 dollars and are now being
sold anywhere from 237 to two thousand
nine hundred and ninety-nine dollars
Gary tweeted us something needs to be
done in this country to curb the
scalping and resale problem while sandy
said don't get it only tickets bought at
ticketmaster should be honored let fans
get the tickets and the band get the
money The Tragically Hip hasn't
addressed the controversy either but
they did announce for additional shows
yesterday that went on fan presale today
due to quote overwhelming demand join
out by course radios Alan cross this
shouldn't reflect poorly on the band but
it does it doesn't have anything to do
with the band what's happening here are
very sophisticated ticket buying
algorithms are going in snatching up
these tickets and then all of a sudden
we see these things on reseller sites it
seems that the people who initially sell
the tickets know that this is a problem
and to a fan it seems like they're not
working fast enough it it does and with
this particular tour the emotion and the
sentiment sentimentality that's attached
to it this is underscored this problem
more than ever thank you very much for
joining us today and for the struggle
for hip fans to get tickets falls in
line with the staggering effect ticket
bots have on sales revealed in the New
York Attorney General's report back in
January in three minutes one bot snapped
up 520 tickets for Beyonce's new york
city show in 2013 it took five minutes
for one bot to grab 522 tickets for One
Direction concert that same year while
in one day to bots took hold of 15,000
tickets to 20 you two shows during their
north american tour in 2014 when Elton
John saw the same price gouging for his
current UK tour he told the BBC I'd
rather have MTC's nothing is extortion
nothing is disgraceful I mean the fact
that they were willing to pay that is
fantastic but i just think i'd rather
than show their money and not come and
adele took it a step further for her
upcoming north american tour by
thwarting scalpers approximately six
point five million dollars by selling a
percentage of her tickets through more
direct avenues to her fans